>>> GET USED TO THAT S
UNLUCKY BREAK FOR THE COLORADO .
BOE
HERE.
>> H WIT
AND KADRI HERE FOR
THE ST. LOUI
GOODE IT DOWN.
LOOSE PUCK, THEY SCORE!
LOGAN  LOOK FOR AN ONSIDE POSSI
.
STRAIGHT ON, NOT MUC
GETTING A PIEC FRONT.
HERE'S THAT PLAY A LITTLE
EARLIER.
RANTANEN CAN'T GET IT BACK.
AN SCHENN.
THIS ONE
>> Shane: KADRI AND LEHKONEN'S
-- COULDN'T GET IT ON NET.
MANSON BLOCKED BY JORDAN.EN LOO
AN INTERFERENCE.
>> Brendan: LEDDY IN AND, JUST
MUFFLER IN FRONT.
BURR O
>> Brendan: AND TO THE MADE BY
AS HUSSO IS GOING TO THE BENCH
AND IT'S GOING OR NOT.
JUSTIN FAULK WAS THE RIGHT  SER
FOR LANDESKOG.
AND HUSSO GOING TO THE.
AVALANCHE BY TWO.
OVERSKATED Barren: THEIR HEAD C
TALKED ABOUT JUST LIKE IN GAME
NUMBER TWO.
IT'S A GAM